JORDAN METZL: Thank you, and
good afternoon, everybody.
It's a pleasure to be back.
This is actually
my third time down,
and today's talk
is about running,
and so this is kind
of a stacked audience.
Last time I was here,
I talked about the book
before this one, which was
on the medicine of exercise
called "The Exercise Cure."
And in that talk, we had
plenty of people of all stripes
that worked down here.
This new book is
all about running,
and so I'm guessing--
raise your hand if you run.
That's what I thought.
All right.
Love to see it.
So today I'm going to talk to
you really from three vantage
points, and when I see
patients in my office,
when I do anything in
terms of education,
when I teach my fitness classes,
and when I do things myself,
I'm really always operating
from three vantage points
simultaneously,
and I think those
are very helpful for me in what
I do in all aspects of this.
So my three vantage
points are, first of all,
as a sports medicine doctor.
So as a sports
medicine doctor, I'm
actively involved in
taking care of patients
and hopefully getting them
better and getting them active
and getting them
out there moving.
And in my office, any
time, it could be anybody
from like an
eight-year-old gymnast to
and 82-year-old lady who's
going to the marathon.
And the commonality between
everybody that comes to see me
is they all want to
move and be active,
and my job is to help
them be active and move.
And through so much of
what you guys do down here,
I've been able to use
technology, I think hopefully,
to make their lives better in
terms of thinking about getting
my message out not in the
one-on-one doctor-patient way,
but in the kind
of mass use, which
I'll talk about at the
end in some of the newer
stuff I've been doing.
So number two perspective
is as an athlete.
This year I did my 33rd
marathon up in Boston,
and I'm training
for the Iron Man
up in Lake Placid this
year, which I do every year,
but this will be
number 13 of those.
And I say that, because I
think everybody in this room
needs a fitness goal.
Now hopefully it's not
doing the Iron Man,
which is kind of a bit
of an extreme type deal.
Anybody ever done
an Iron Man in here?
Oh, good.
Good job, man.
So it's a 2.4 mile swim, a
112 mile bike ride, and then
a marathon which
is a little cray,
but the nice thing about
that is that it really
is a great goal every
year, and it keeps you
from probably doing other
stuff you shouldn't be doing.
So it's great to give a
goal, and as an athlete,
I love the idea of giving
myself a goal that's
a little bit outside my
comfort zone every single year,
and that's the Iron Man for me.
And then number three is
as a fitness instructor.
So about four years ago, you'll
see at the end of this talk,
I started a fitness series
called Iron Strength, which is
free, community-based fitness.
I started with about 25 people.
This is now a class of
not only many thousands
locally here that come do
these different classes,
but we did a whole series
of runnersworld.com online,
and so my workout's
been done now
by about 10 million
people around the world.
And it's been great to
kind of teach runners
how to make their body stronger
so they don't get hurt.
And so that's the
last perspective
is as a fitness instructor,
I'm actively involved now.
I'm going to send out after
this lecture, and on my website
here, you can see under the Iron
Strength calendar, the workouts
that I do.
The next one is actually
just around the corner
on Tuesday evening.
It's a big free workout at 6:30
down on Pier 25 literally right
out the door near here.
With the beautiful
weather, there's
nothing better than doing some
sunset burpees on the Hudson
River while I kick your butt
in a very meaningful way,
so I hope you guys can come
out and check that out.
I'll send around the
flier as well afterwards.
So it's with those three
perspectives as a doctor,
as an athlete, and as
a fitness instructor,
I really approach
all the things that I
do in terms of trying
to educate athletes
about how to take better
care of their bodies,
how to be injury
free when possible,
and how to basically
stay out of my office
and stay off doing
what they're doing.
And so with all that, I'm going
to talk about running strong,
and in the end,
I'll talk about some
of the new tech features, which
were really exciting to me.
And I've had a bunch
of you guys come up
as patients at different
times, and as I've
been working through this,
and I showed some of you guys
this in the infancy
before it came out
and then when it was published.
And it always makes
me so happy when
I see a Googler who comes
up, and I show them this,
and they're like, wow.
That's cool.
That makes me feel like
I'm onto something here,
because if you guys think it's
cool, then I know it's cool.
So we're going to
talk this morning
about how you're going to become
the best runner you can be.
And guys in the back, there's
some videos we'll play,
and I'll kind of call
those out as we go forth.
So first of all, let's
talk about what's
going to make you the
healthiest runner you can be.
And for those
sitting on the sides,
if you guys want
to-- I just don't
want you to come in with a
twisted neck in my office.
It may be tough to see
the screen that way.
So when you want
to run, my thought
is from my doctor perspective,
how do we-- that's a good idea.
Way to turn your chair.
So how do we think about
keeping you as a healthy runner?
And so first of
all, I think part
of that is identifying what
kind of runner you are.
Number two is I want
to talk then about some
of the different injury
patterns we're seeing
and some of the different
uses of a kind of injury
mechanical screening and
biomechanical analysis
we're doing down
at the hospital.
And then lastly, talk about
preventive strategies as we
go forth thinking about the keys
to becoming a healthy runner,
because from my
perspective, whether or not
you win the New York City
Marathon, which chances are
nobody in this room is actually
going to win the marathon,
but maybe you are,
but I doubt it.
But from my
perspective, the key is
I want you running because
as a sports medicine doctor,
and as a doctor in
general, I deeply
believe that the
best medicine we have
is the medicine of exercising,
getting people out there
to take every day
is so important,
and I'm really dedicated
to getting people
to do that and have really
been actively involved
in getting that message out.
We just started at Cornell this
year a second year med student
curriculum on teaching exercise
as medicine to the second year
med students, because
unfortunately, most health care
professionals have no idea
how to prescribe exercise,
yet this is the most readily
available drug we have,
which is not only fully
efficacious and safe,
but anybody can take it at
any age, and it always works.
And that's a pretty great
drug, and it's free.
So teaching people how
to take that medicine
and think about
it in those terms
is a lot about what I've
been interested in doing.
And then finally, we'll
talk about off to the races
and what you can do to basically
build your own training plans,
and I'll talk through
some of the things
in "Running Strong," the new
book with Runner's World.
So basically thinking about
running is nothing new,
and this is pretty much
the oldest sport we have.
And so for those of
you in need of a run,
you're part of a long
lineage of runners
from many, many hundreds
of thousands of years ago.
We've been running since we've
been walking, essentially,
and it's a big piece
of what has been
depicted throughout history.
Now there have been
different attempts
to look at what makes the
healthiest and most efficacious
way to run.
And people have tried
throughout history
to figure out what's the
most anatomically perfect,
what's the fastest, what's
the most injury free,
and this is nothing really new.
I think the thing I'm
really excited about is
the interface between the
world that you guys live in
and the world that
I live in, and I
think that's great
for everything
from how much activity
somebody's doing
per day to what kind of
activity they're doing per day.
And you guys are giving us
tools to evaluate what people
are doing in a very different
way than we used to do,
which is, I think, terrific.
When we look at today's
running culture, more than 35
million runners.
10 million run more
than 100 days per year.
There were 137 people in the
first New York City Marathon
back in 1970.
There were 47,000,
more than, in 2014.
Who here has run the
New York Marathon?
Good, so almost half the room.
And great event, great thing
to think about one time
in your life, at least once in
your life as something to just
do as a bucket list.
So sports medicine,
and as we have
dealt with this concept
of what running is
and what prevention looks like
has really evolved as well.
So the first textbook on
running was back in 1975.
And we've hopefully
come a long way
in terms of educating people
about how to do this healthily.
So let's kind of go through
some of these questions.
First of all, what
kind of runner are you?
And the answer is if I
look around this room,
or this is actually last
year's class on Pier 25,
so this is where
we're going to be.
This is where we're going
to be on Tuesday night,
and if you look at this
picture here on the screen,
you'll see people who are
running for different reasons.
So down there on the
lower left hand corner,
you'll see some people
in the neon green shirts.
They are guides for a
couple of the runners
down in the corner who
are Achilles runners.
So the two people, the
guy with the headband,
and the woman just in
back of him in the white
are both blind runners who are
part of the Achilles program
who have guides, and Achilles
is a great organization
which gets people with
physical disabilities
and gets them out and moving
and active and running
among other things.
And so these people are
runners, because they
want to feel like they're part
of a community when it may
be tougher for them to do that.
On the right hand side of
the lower part of the picture
are women from a great
organization that I'm
involved with called
Black Girls Run,
and Black Girls Run
is an organization
which has really used
running to target members
of the African
American community, who
tend to want to be active
and don't have a ton of ways
to do that or to think about
it and have really targeted
African American women.
And so their organization
is all about getting women
out running in their community,
and they're great role models,
and they bring tons of their
friends to our classes,
and they're running
because they want
to promote health and wellness.
In the middle of
the picture, you
might see somebody who might be
a kind of a 235 or 240 marathon
who wants to get stronger,
so they can break their time.
And those people are running
because they're elite,
and they want to be super elite.
And then in the
middle, you see people
who are kind of in their 60s
and 70s who may have arthritis,
and they want to strength
train so their knees don't hurt
and they can keep moving.
And so the answer is
that in this room,
people are running for health.
People are running
for weight loss.
People are running for socials.
People are running because
it makes them feel good.
People are running because it
makes their brain work better.
People are running
because they had
a parent who had heart
disease, and they don't
want to have heart disease.
People are running for any
number of reasons in this room,
and the answer is
they're all great.
But the problem is
that when you come
to see me as a 255 runner
who wants to break 250
like our patient
here or so, or when
you come to see me
as somebody who's
got arthritis in
your knees, and you
want to keep running when you're
70, the way we think about
you is different.
And so there's not
a one size fits
all in terms of running
programs, training programs,
running mechanics,
running, frequency.
You really have to think about
the differences in your body
when you make yourself
the healthiest runner,
because everybody runs because
it makes them feel good,
but I want you to keep running
for decades, for centuries.
Now part of this discussion
begins with the body type
that you have, and everybody
has a different body.
And so part of that in my
office is the endomorph,
who tends to basically
have a heavier body type,
and no matter what they do,
they have a heavier body type.
Now that person,
it's tougher for them
to run tons and tons of miles.
Does that mean they can't?
Absolutely not, but it means
we train them differently.
They need much more strength
training, less high mileage
running, and really they
need to work actively
on their short stride
high cadenced run
as I'll talk about in a second.
The mesomorphs
have the best deal
in that they have bodies which
are applicable to anything.
They can do any sport, and
they tend to build muscle.
They tend to build
strength relatively easily.
The ectomorphs tend not to build
muscle and strength no matter
what they do.
Those are the long, lanky people
who tend, whatever they do,
they tend to get problems of
bone injuries, particularly.
They tend to get a lot
of stress fractures.
For those guys, much
like our endomorphs,
we need to really
emphasize the strength.
We need to diminish
the run volume,
but knowing your run
body makes a difference,
and it makes a
difference for any sport.
When I see people in my office
of-- I have a number of people
I see that want to be dancers
at the School of American
Ballet, kids who don't have
proper turnout in their hips,
or they don't have
great ballet feet,
or they don't have great laxity
to become great swimmers.
Here's a great test.
Everybody take your wrist.
Bend your wrist
down just like I am.
Take your thumb, and
push your thumb back
towards your radius bone.
If anybody's thumb is
touching their radius bone
when they push, hold your
arm straight up in the air.
So hold your arm if you're--
right there, there's one.
Are you guys touching
in the back back there?
I can't see.
Don't hurt yourself.
That's fine.
So this guy's
definitely touching.
Who else is touching?
You in the front.
What do you say?
Yeah, hold your arm
up there in the red.
Is that touching?
No, you're not.
Forget it.
This guy, are you
touching, dude?
Yeah, he is.
Who else?
Anybody else?
Just one and two.
These two guys and you two.
Hold your arm up nice and tall.
See, the middle section's
got it going on.
Sorry, guys.
So what these three
guys are is they
have the best body
type for swimming.
Now you may be a bad swimmer.
You may hate swimming.
I can't control that, but
if you have good technique,
and if you're
interested in swimming,
you would naturally
be a good swimmer.
Why?
Because every swimmer
does best when
they streamline when they
get their arm all the way up
and all the way up.
When you have
ligamentous laxity there,
it means you have generalized
ligamentous laxity.
It means that you can streamline
much better than your friends,
and what that ends up meaning
is you're like a sardine.
You can just go zipping
straight down the pool.
So when we do kind of screening
tests of the US Olympic
swimming team, they all
have ligamentous laxity
as part of their body profile.
So does that mean you're
going to be a great swimmer?
No, maybe you hate swimming
and have no idea how to swim.
But if you know how to
swim, if you love swimming,
and if you put a lot of time
into swimming, the body type
you have favors
swimming, for example.
And that's true with
any sport that I see.
I see the biggest problems
when people try and say,
listen, my person working
next to me here at Google,
she runs 60, 70 miles a week.
Why can't I run 70 miles a week?
And the answer is you may
have a very different body.
And so what works for
her may not work for you,
and when that happens, then
we start to see injuries.
So picking the right body
for the right activity
is important, and
this guy taught
us a lot about different
characteristics that
are favored by
whatever it is you do.
So in any animal
species we see, there
are characteristics that
are favored for and favored
against.
And so certainly, there
are different pressures.
But in general, I
always think about that,
and to me, the best
depiction of this
is in Japan, where every
year for some freaky reason,
they take their sumo wrestlers
and on national TV-- and guys
this is a video.
You can just hit down
in the lower left hand
corner of my screen
and get that started.
There is-- is
somebody over there?
So just kind of move
the cursor over there,
and you'll find a little video.
Right there, yep.
Just click on that.
Back up one.
There you go.
So every year-- we'll
have a few of these,
so just keep coming up.
So every year, they
take their sumos,
and they run them
down the middle
of the street on national TV,
and the reason this is helpful
is this guy is actually
one of the champion sumos.
He's exceptionally
well-built for sumo.
He's not exceptionally
well-built for sprinting.
And so this kind of
graphic illustration
really helps kind of think
about body type for sport
now does that mean I couldn't
train him to run a marathon?
Absolutely not.
He could run a
marathon probably,
but it'd be a very
different training
program than somebody else.
And so thinking about
that and thinking
that there's not a one size fits
all I think is very important.
Now the truth is if you want
to do a marathon, you can.
You look at some
celebrities, and you
think Oprah ran a marathon,
Will Farrell ran a marathon.
You could definitely
run a marathon.
It's just the way
we think about doing
that is very different
person to person.
So how can I find out
what kind of runner I am,
because I want you
running forever.
And the answer is, how
often am I running?
How intense am I running?
Am I running super
intense, five days a week,
Am I just going to
couple times a week?
Am I doing this, a
little bit, a lot bit?
If I had any injuries
before, that always plays in.
Am I somebody who tore my ACL
when I was playing high school
soccer, and now I have
arthritis in my knee or my hip,
and that changes how much
I can do and how I train.
What are my running goals?
There's a lot to
think about when
we think about picking the right
runner for the right sport.
Now people interface with
me often when they're hurt.
So they come in to see me,
and so what I'm trying to do
is trying to back up this
discussion before people
get hurt, because unfortunately,
they always come in
to see me with their
injury, and then we
think about why it happened,
how we could prevent it,
and I'm super into that.
But on a bigger scale,
on the educational side,
I'm more into keeping
people well rather
than waiting until they break.
So when we think about
running injuries,
there's a couple
things to think about.
About a third of runners will
get hurt every year running.
That's a pretty high number.
Injury sites are
basically mostly
everything from the waist down.
These are some of
the common things,
and you probably recognize
some of your friends
up there when I put
that list up there.
Who here's had a running injury?
Just let's see a show of hands.
So that's at least
a third of the room.
Looks like more
than half the room,
and I guess that's
why you're here.
And then knees are some of the
people, so the first timers who
tend not to have
as much knowledge,
and they tend not to be
as strong tend to get
hurt much more frequently.
Now walkers versus
runners, and the answer
is that when you walk, you put
70% to 80% of your body weight
across your skeleton,
so your back
your hips, your
knees, your ankles.
When you run, you put about
300% of your body weight
across your backs, your knees,
your hips, and your ankles.
So the exponential loading
for us, people are like, well,
I've been walking forever,
and I never had shin splints.
Now I'm running, and
I've got shin splints.
Why?
The answer is when you're
putting three times
relative more body
weight across your shins,
your ankles, your hips,
your knees, et cetera,
so the ground reactive force--
the force between the ground
and your body--
increases exponentially,
and that puts much more load.
So if your foot pronates
or rolls in a lot,
and you're applying x amount
of force per gate cycle,
and then you start running, and
you make that x times 3 or 4,
much more loading force.
Hence bone is like, this sucks.
It starts to get sore.
You get a stress injury.
You get a stress
fracture, and that's
why those injuries
tend to happen.
Now the key here is that
running is basically
a series of jumps from one
foot to the next in a series
that we call
plyometric-based jumps.
If you come to my
class on Tuesday,
you're going to be like,
dude, you're killing me.
And I hate these plyometrics,
and the answer is great,
because running is a plyometric
from one leg to the next,
and if you don't train
a plyometric activity
with plyometrics, you
end up getting hurt.
So just running alone is not
going to get you strong enough
to run injury free.
That's why I called the
book "Running Strong,"
because I want people
to be stronger when they
run so they don't get hurt.
So why do people get hurt?
And the answers are basically
a whole host of factors.
And when I think about these,
and somebody comes to see me,
I think about these as the
intrinsic, meaning changes
happening outside the body.
Extrinsic, changes
happening outside the body,
and the intrinsic changes
from inside your body.
And both these together,
these lists together
combine to create injury.
Now everybody has a
different piece on this list,
and these things can include
your training plan, what kind
of shoes you pick,
nutrition plays
a role on the extrinsic factor.
What about inside your body?
What kind of body
type you have-- we
talked about that already.
What kind of injuries
you've had in the past.
Your stride is a huge piece,
stride mechanics, stride
cadence, stride frequency.
We call vertical displacement,
which all relates
to ground reactive force.
I'll show you what
that means in a second.
Your brain, which is part
of your intrinsic thing.
Are you like somebody
that's like running,
and you keep a good
balance, or are you
like, I must run 10 miles,
I must run 10 miles.
Those people get hurt a lot.
Does about kinetic chain issues?
Are you taking good care
of your kinetic chain?
Are you working on
your flexibility?
Who here owns a foam roller?
All right, could see
some more hands there.
And who hear does strength
training pretty regularly?
I can see some more hands there.
So we've got all
runners in here,
and again, these are some
of the things I think about.
So all of these things
make a difference
when we think about this.
So kinetic chain is a
combination of your strength
and flexibility.
So I'll talk about all
these things for a sec.
So extrinsic factors, things
happening outside your body--
so the typical person
that comes to see me
may be somebody who's doing
this a lot of the day, and then
is like, all right.
The New York Marathon
is in November.
I got a number.
Come September, October,
I'd better get training.
I better start.
I'm going to do this.
And I can't tell you.
Now I know my sample population
is biased, because they come
see me when they're
hurt, but dude, people
come in to see me all the
training for the marathon
like two months ago.
And it takes awhile,
especially if you're just
starting out to do this.
And so I called this a violation
of the rules of toos, which
is kind of too much, too fast.
And you end up ramping up your
training very, very quickly.
Actually, the back
of the book, I
have a whole series of training
plans for every distance race
that go out about four months.
And so if you're going to
train for the marathon,
the time to start is now.
This is the time to start
base building for the marathon
if you're not
doing that already.
Slow and steady build,
and everybody's different.
If you were a college
soccer player,
and you're two years
out of college,
you're coming into this
with a much different base
than if you had three
kids, and you're like 45,
and now you want to start
getting back into fitness.
That's a different person,
and so you both can do it,
but you've got to train
very differently to do it.
There's not a one size fits
all, and certainly based fitness
is part of this discussion.
So in the top here is a
choice which is probably
important in your life.
But as a runner, dude,
the bottom choice
is probably, that's
probably more important.
Like getting the
right pair of running
shoes is like a hugely
important choice in your life.
So you want to make sure
that when you walk down
the aisle with
your running shoes,
you make a good decision.
Now what are some of the things
I see that people do wrong?
And the answer is
I like these ones.
I like the color.
I read about these.
I read "Born to Run."
I want to be a
minimalist runner.
Famous runners wear these shoes.
These are some of
the common things
that you would be surprised
how often these factors lead
to decision making.
And so the answer is that I
think that part of the issue
is that people feel
somewhat, have been made to
and feel somewhat insecure when
they walk into a running shoe
store.
And so they're
looking to be led,
and they can be led by
somebody who's like,
run on this treadmill,
and let's see what you do.
The truth of the matter
is a different shoe,
different companies
carry different shoes,
they have an interest in
promoting different shoes.
And you can be very
easily swayed, I think,
in that circumstance.
So what I'm going to
tell you is that you've
got to trust yourself
when you go in there.
If it feels supportive
and comfortable,
it's supportive and comfortable.
If it feels not supportive
and not comfortable,
it's not supportive,
it's not comfortable.
And running shoes
should be comfortable,
and they should be
supportive, and I'll
talk about foot
mechanic in a second.
But I want you to be
confident in saying,
I like how this feels, or I
don't like how this feels.
And if you can try and take
out the top part of this,
I mean, if they're
hideous, all right.
Hideous you get a
pass on hideous.
But otherwise, I think that
if you guys can try and think
about, listen, I'm here.
I know it feels good.
I want you to be confident in
that decision making process.
I think it makes
a big difference.
So how do I choose the
right running shoe?
Well, there's
different categories.
There's racing flats.
There's the typical
high mileage shoe.
There are running spikes
if you're doing track,
and there's a neutral shoe.
There's a motion control, which
prevents you from rolling in.
There's a minimalist shoe,
which anybody here running
in minimalist type shoes,
the very light, and that
encourages a high cadence
short stride run, which I love.
I will make the
comment that you do not
need a minimalist shoe
to get the benefit
from that cadence type.
You can also do
that cadence type
and learn with short
mileage on a minimalist
and then transition
over, or I'm sure I'll
hear during the Q&A, stories
of how people started.
Maybe they got hurt, or
they loved it right away.
It's always kind of interesting
to see how people got there.
But the point is that
this is a process,
and as you kind of pick
the right pair of shoes,
I want you to be
confident in doing that.
Now I'm going to show
you two videos here.
If we can just play the
video on the lower left,
and I want you to show
this person running,
and I want you
look at these feet
when they hit the treadmill.
Everybody see how this person
hits and rolls into the middle.
Let's play that one more
time on the left, and that's
called late pronation.
Hit, roll in, hit,
roll in, hit, roll in.
Everybody see that person?
Now that may be
somebody that comes in
to see me with really bad
shin splints or very bad pain
in the front of their
knee called runner's knee.
And it all starts with
the feet, and so that
may be something that
we think about in terms
of correct their shoe.
It may be somebody
where we think
about correcting something
with an arch support
inside their shoe, maybe both.
What I hope for is let's play
this person on the right.
The person on the
right is somebody
who hits and pushes
pretty much straight off.
Everybody see the difference
how that foot does not
roll in it all.
And so that's a much more evenly
distributed force mechanic,
so people that get shin
splints when they run a lot,
tend to be rolling too much
like the person on the left.
And so we want you to look
like the person on the right.
Ah, thanks, good artistic
license back there.
I support that.
And so you can see the person
on the left is rolling.
The person on the right
is pretty much neutral,
and I want you to be close
to neutral if you can.
Now there are a lot
of ways to get there,
and there's not a one
size fits all Some people
like doing at their shoes
that have motion control.
They prevent you from rolling.
There are some people
who get an arch support,
and I'm a big believer of
the $45-- on my website,
and I left cards at
the back with my site.
I've got links to
pretty much everything.
The site I like
for arch supports
is the link called Sole.
And these are basically
you order some orthotics
from Canada for like $45.
You put them in the oven.
You heat them, and
then you step in them,
and they harden and mold to
your feet, and they work great.
I have all of my patients
pretty much get those
if they're rolling.
And so I may put them in a
neutral shoe with an orthotic.
If they need like the
whole heavy hitter,
I put them in a motion
control shoe with an orthotic.
Not everybody needs that.
That's a lot of motion control.
The point is I want
you to look closer
to the runner on the right
than the runner on the left,
if possible.
Now lastly on the
extrinsic nutrition,
now this is a whole
talk in and of itself.
What are some of the common
things that we think about?
Well, there's certainly
nutrition during training.
You may have seen a very
interesting blog post yesterday
on the New York Times site
asking the question, in order
to lose weight, is it better
to exercise or not eat as much?
And the answer is basically
that it's much easier
to lose weight, if losing
weight's you're only goal,
by diet than by exercise.
But the problem is that
that doesn't give you
the health benefits.
So I'd much rather
people be mildly
to moderately
overweight and active
than very skinny and inactive.
The health benefits come with
activity, not with body type
at all.
That being said,
how you eat and how
you trained her when
you eat, changes
when you start training
for endurance events.
And so certainly, when you
have a higher appetite,
and when you eat-- we want
you eating within a half hour
at the end of your workout to
replenish your muscle glycogen
stores-- we think about
how to optimize nutrition,
and there's certainly
nutrition during events.
And we see a lot of questions
in the office about muscle
cramping.
I tackle some of that as well.
Low sodium, which can lead
to muscle strain and muscle
injury and a lot of
cramps, and there's a lot
now on trying to prevent muscle
cramping through good sodium
pre-sodium, so pretzels
and salty foods
before you run endurance events.
Some salty foods during
events make a big difference,
and different people
have different amounts
of sodium in their sweat.
So everybody in here
sweats a different amount,
and they sweat a different
concentration of sodium.
So if you're somebody
who tends to cramp,
most likely you're
a big salt loser,
and we want you to try and
replenish your sodium stores
before and during exercise
with anything salty.
My tennis players, by the
way, love dill pickle juice.
It's by far the most readily
available and absorbable sodium
source.
It works great for muscle
cramping and prevention.
But it kind of-- dill pickle
juice, so that's the problem.
All right.
Let's talk about
changes in your body.
So changes in your body--
we've talked about changes
outside your body.
What about in your body can
make you a healthy runner?
And the answer is that there's
the mind, and there's the body.
And these are some of
the things in the mind.
When the body comes in,
genetics, attention to injury
form, and kinetic chain.
So let's talk about the mind.
Now I will tell you
that I think that if it
doesn't hurt a little bit,
you're not doing it right.
It should not be fully
comfortable all the time,
and I mean that both
physically and mentally.
If you're not pushing
yourself-- I'm not a sadist,
I don't think--
but if you're not
getting a little bit of pain,
you're not getting better.
And so I think the concept of
no pain, no gain is helpful.
But there's healthy pain,
and there's unhealthy pain.
And the answer is healthy
pain is pain, and I'm done,
and it's not horrid.
Unhealthy pain is
like I'm limping down
the hall, because I did a run.
So generally, unhealthy
pain changes your mechanic
of movement.
If you're getting that, you've
got to get it checked out.
But in general,
training, when you train,
we want you to
train-- certainly,
part of your training should
be mental toughness as well.
And I do think it has to
be a bit uncomfortable.
I think there's a whole process
of training for an event, which
is kind of callousing
your mind, which
is as important as callousing
your body to some of the things
you'll run into when you
do an endurance event.
And I think mental skills
training carries over
to all aspects of life, and
I think that those are all
important things.
Now in the body type, I've
already made the point
that the kind of body
you have and [INAUDIBLE]
your body anthropomorphics,
your skeleton, your foot type,
your knee-- is there
arthritis in your knee--
your hip, what your hip is built
like, how much rotation you
have in your hip, how much
arthritis is in your hip,
your back.
Do you have a herniated disc in
your back, which means we have
to train you a bit differently.
There's so many factors
that people deal with,
and my hope is to make everybody
educated in how to kind of make
themselves the most efficient
and injury free runner
on their own, because you could
spend your entire life going
to physical therapy and massage
therapy, whatever, and I want
you guys to be--
I want you really
learn how to do most of
this stuff on your own
when possible.
This is somebody
who's got arthritis
underneath their kneecap.
That's a picture of a kneecap.
There should be a space
underneath that kneecap.
Unfortunately, on the
outside part of the picture,
the kneecap is literally sitting
right against the femur bone,
so that somebody's got
an arthritic knee who
wants to run, and
the answer is that we
do things like strengthening
and whatever else,
and we are now
trying things like
these injectables synthetic
lubricant shots like WD-40
for their knee that
we put into their knee
to help them so they can move.
Because again, it may
just be their knee,
but if they're not taking
the medicine and exercise,
it's affecting their
blood pressure,
their psyche, their
heart, they're everything.
So life gets worse when
you can't move for sure,
so I want them to
be able to move.
Now the knee is the most
commonly injured body part.
It's kind of trapped between
the hip and the ground,
and so we want to think
about the factors that
cause knee pain, including
factors happening
from the ground up, factors
happening from the hip down,
and really address
both of those.
Same thing with
things like tendons.
An Achilles tendon.
This is somebody coming in
to see me with a chronically
achy Achilles tendon.
They had Achilles tendinitis.
They didn't try and fix it,
didn't pay attention over time,
the tendons started
to thicken, so it
goes from what's
called tendinitis
to what's called tendinosis.
It gets very, very thick
and chronically injured,
so on this person,
we ended up doing
after nothing else
worked, something
called a PRP, where we
took blood from their arm,
spun it down, took
their own platelets,
and injected it into the
tendon to get it to heal,
and it worked great.
The idea is I want you
try and prevent this
from getting to that point,
but injuries can show up
in any different place.
Also in bone, people who
don't pay good attention
to their injury symptoms
end up with things
like stress fractures, where
the bone on the right hand side
is starting to crack,
because they're not
listening to their body.
So pain that changes your
mechanic of activity,
get it checked out.
That's important.
Now what about running mechanic?
Is there a perfect way to run?
And the answer is that everybody
runs a little bit differently,
but there are
certainly some things
which make healthier
runners, including
we know that high cadence, short
stride runners are hurt less.
We know that runners
that bounce less
are hurt less, less
vertical displacement.
They don't pop up
in the air as much,
and those things are related.
When you have a short
stride, high cadence,
you're not popping up
as much, and you have
less ground reactive voice.
You're not crashing
into the ground as much.
I get the question all
the time-- treadmills
versus outside versus
asphalt versus dirt,
and the answer is
there's no answer.
Whatever is most
comfortable for you,
and we'll get you into
that mechanic that I want,
I'm cool with.
So what are the things that we
think about when somebody comes
in for their running stride?
And again, I want people to kind
of start reading about this,
thinking about it,
learning about it.
How much height you have-- are
you popping up in the ground?
Your stride speed,
your stride length.
When you think I
want to run faster,
I don't want you think I'm
going to stretch out my legs as
long as I possibly can.
I want you to think I want
to increase my turnover.
Your stride angle as
well as your cadence,
which should be about 160 or
so per minute or 80 per side,
so your left foot should hit
the ground about 80 times
per minute.
So what are some
ways to do that?
You can just look at your watch
and give yourself a minute,
and see how many times your
left foot hits the ground.
Or there's some great new apps.
A great app I love
called Spring Moves
is an app where you
can basically pick
a song that's cadence-based.
So you say, I want to run 160 or
150, they'll pick music for you
in that range.
Or Spotify came out a couple
weeks ago with a running app,
where on Spotify, the reason
I think this is going to be,
from my perspective,
not as good,
is that if you're
like a 150 runner,
it'll pick music
that's 150 for you.
The problem is your
cadence isn't quick enough,
and now you're listening to
music, which is basically
consistent with that cadence.
And so you're just going
to run the same pace,
because you're not
being encouraged
to quicken that a little bit.
So I like the idea setting
cadence like a metronome to try
and basically quick
up how you move.
What are the
characteristics of somebody
that's a very efficient runner?
Well, they basically
have a short stride.
They tend to run without
wiggling all over the place.
They have a very limited
arm swing straight ahead,
not crossing over
their body as much.
They don't have as much very
smooth, relaxed upper body
motion, and they don't
pop up and down as much.
They're pretty stable from--
if you're ever out looking
at the leaders of a race
like the marathon, the people
close to the front, they are
not popping up very much.
They're pretty quiet
from the waist up.
They look like
nothing's happening.
All the action is happening
from the waist down,
and that's a good,
efficient runner.
Now gait cycle is basically
how we measure gait,
and that's from your
right foot leaves
to your right foot comes
back to that same position,
and when one foot
hits the ground
to when the same foot
hits the ground again,
it's called your gait cycle.
So we start to look at
some of these things,
and some of the factors that
control how shock is absorbed
in your gait cycle include how
much ankle motion you have,
how much flexion of your
hip and knee you have.
And again, if you have
an arthritic knee or hip,
it can affect how
much flexion you have,
which can affect how
you absorb stress.
Now that I'll talk
about in a second
is something which is
changeable somewhat,
but it may not be
fully changeable.
So we think about
everything we can
do to try and make you
the best version of you
you can, but at the end of
the day, you're still you.
So we have to make you
the best you you can be.
That's Y-O-U, not
E-W-E, by the way.
So eccentric muscle force,
how strong your muscles are.
Again, stronger muscles
produce less loading force
on knees and hips
and backs, and so
if somebody has like
a herniated disc,
and they see me, and like,
dude, I can never run again,
the answer is no.
We're going to strengthen the
heck out of your core muscles
that will unload that back
and allow you to do more,
and hopefully, that alone
is all we have to do,
which it often is the
case for many patients
as well as cartilage.
Your cartilage is also
helpful to help absorb stress
from the road.
Now had a couple
minimalist runners here,
and I think a lot of this
research on minimalist running
has come historically in Africa,
where many of the great runners
come from.
There is basically a
whole push, and there
was kind of going back
to what people did,
which was barefoot running.
And that's where this whole
concept of minimalist running
came from, which is from
whole groups of people
who don't wear shoes at all or
wear tire treads or nothing.
So let's play this
video, and I want you
to watch where this guy lands.
So this is an African runner,
and look at where he lands.
He hits on the outside
part of his foot.
His foot absorbs the
stress of the ground,
and you'll see it
widen a little bit.
And I want you look at the
angle between his knee, his hip,
and his body as he pushes
through that run mechanic.
So he's basically running with
a relatively short stride.
He's a sprinter.
A relatively short
stride, but when
you look when he
hits the ground,
he's basically
lining up exactly.
Good job in the back there.
He's lining up exactly his
foot, his knee, and his hip.
His foot is basically almost
directly underneath him
when he maximally loads that.
Now for my minimalist
guys and gals in here,
you're doing that
already, because the shoe
type you're wearing, which
is why it feels so good,
is basically keeping you
in almost that exact gait
mechanic pattern.
Now you do not need that shoe or
no shoes to be able to do that.
And who's read
"Born to Run," which
is a whole book about this?
So when "Born to Run"
came out, my office
was-- it was a book about this
whole tribe of Mexican Indians
who basically ran
with no shoes and how
they were hurt much less and the
whole kind of idea about that.
And so when that book came
out, for the next six months,
my office was overflowing
wannabe Mexican Indians who
were trying to run
barefoot in Central Park,
and they had all
kinds of problems.
And the answer is,
you do not need
to run barefoot or even
minimalist to get this stride,
but the whole idea
is the short stride,
high cadence run mechanic.
And so we don't want that
foot way out in front of you,
because you come crashing down.
All that force comes directly
up through the ground,
and you end up
hurting yourselves.
How can you learn to do this?
Well, things I talked about such
as counting cadence, shortening
stride, uphill training is a
great thing to think about.
My class, I do outdoors in
Central Park in the mornings.
Who's been to my
class, by the way?
Anybody in here?
A few of you guys, good.
Hopefully, you lived
to tell about it.
And the outdoor
center park classes,
we do some component
of running, and hill
running to encourage people
to shorten their stride
and quicken their cadence.
Now what we're doing now, and
this is a video on the left,
the lower left is
we're in the lab.
We are looking at
stride mechanic,
so you can just play that video
on the lower left if you can.
Good.
Stride mechanic and
trying to measure out
people's angle of motion
and what it looks like
and what the optimal
run mechanic is for you.
Again, you don't have to
come to us to get this done.
You can start just
mimicking this on your own,
but it's pretty cool
to see how we are now
kind of using a
lot of the things
you guys developed to help us
in terms of this discussion.
What about your body?
Well, your kinetic chain
is a big piece of this,
and so the kinetic
chain is a combination
of strength and flexibility.
And it's important, because if
you're running like this person
here on the left,
and your left knee is
falling into the middle,
she's got very weak muscles.
Her hip is kind of falling in.
She's what we would call
a Trendelenburg posture,
meaning her hip is falling.
So she's somebody
who's going to get hurt
if she does that often enough.
So her anatomy plays a role.
Her ankle and foot
mechanics play a role,
but understanding how
all this works together
makes a big difference in terms
of for injury predisposition,
because what I
want you guys to do
is to push that injury
threshold out further.
And the way you will do
that is a combination
of your flexibility, and so
in the back of [INAUDIBLE]
I have a whole thing of the nine
things to do with your roller
every single day,
and I want to do
that to loosen up those
muscles, which I think
is actually more
efficient than stretching
and yoga and strengthening.
So the question is,
who can strength train?
And the answer is yes.
In my classes, anybody from
like 10 to 80 have come.
I have an 82-year-old
lady who came to class.
Let's have a look at this
video, and let's watch
this strength trainer who
started strength training
at 91.
Oh, let's not look
at that video.
So this is a video--
just kidding--
this is a video
which kind of talked
about somebody who came
in and started a strength
program at age 91.
And the benefits for her were
everything from not falling
is much to not
falling at all to kind
of moving without a problem.
And so the idea
here is that there's
so much you can do at any
age to build strength.
Now I'm going to play
you two videos here.
Let's click the
video on the left.
That's her stepping
down with her left foot.
The right leg is on the box.
Let's play the
video on the right.
This is the left leg stepping
down, the right leg--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Whenever you're ready,
step down nice and slow.
Good job.
All the way down.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JORDAN METZL: OK, great.
Now she came in to
see me with an injury.
Did she come in to see me
because her right knee was hurt
or her left knee was hurt?
I'm watching her step
down off the box.
Who here votes for right knee?
Who here votes for left knee?
All right.
So most of you guys didn't vote.
That's OK.
Now I want you to watch
these videos one more time.
When you-- well, not yet.
Now when she steps down with the
right foot, as she steps down,
I want you to pay very--
don't be distracted.
I want you to watch
her right knee,
and I want you look at the
angle between her foot,
her right knee, and her
hip as she steps down
off the box, the knee
that's on the box.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Other leg now.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JORDAN METZL: OK.
Now the same thing
on the other side.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-OK, whenever you're ready,
step down nice and slow.
Good job.
All the way down.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JORDAN METZL: All right.
What did you guys see
side-to-side difference?
Who saw a difference?
What'd you see?
AUDIENCE: The right knee
didn't stay straight.
JORDAN METZL: The right
knee did not stay straight.
The right knee drifted
in towards the middle.
So you remember that
girl I showed you
in the beginning whose
hip was falling in.
So she has one of the dreaded
problems in runners called
WBS, or weak butt syndrome.
A weak butt is a
disaster for a runner,
because what ends
up happening is
when you land from
your running stride,
that knee and hip
falls into the middle.
And you end up getting shin
splints, plantar fasciitis,
knee pain, hip pain-- all
these problems tend to be,
oftentimes, not always,
because sometimes you
have some of the underlying
problems I've talked about,
because you're so weak.
And so she's very much
weaker on that side
where she's stepping
down off the box,
and that right side is
weaker than the left side.
And everybody in this room
has strength differences side
to side.
So what I've tried
to do, let's see
if there's a video here first.
There should be, hopefully.
Back up one.
Hold on.
Let's stop.
Now we got it.
Good.
So what I've tried to do is
to build this strength workout
to get people to move.
So last year, actually, the New
York Times came out last summer
and visited my
class, and so this
was one of our
Central Park classes,
which was a combination of
strength training and running
together.
This kind of gives you a
story about what it's about,
and I'll get to you in one sec.
So let's go ahead and
put the volume up,
and let's watch this video now.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-My name is Dr. Jordan Metzl.
I'm a sports medicine
physician at Hospital
for Special Surgery, and we're
in Central Park having just
done my iron strength workout.
As a doctor, I really believe
that exercise is the best
medicine, and I
want everybody to be
able to take that
medicine all the time.
The first time I
did it, I thought,
I wonder if anybody's
going to come.
I just emailed some
of my patients.
We had about 25 people.
I've now built the
listserv for this class
of about 6,000 people.
This kind of workout's
great about twice a week,
and the great thing
about it is it's free.
You don't need any equipment,
and it's so effective.
I think body weight
strengthening
and what's called functional
strength training is the way
to go.
Today we did a combination
of, first of all, some
skipping up a hill.
Skipping is a great
example of what's
called a plyometric, so the
muscles basically rapidly
elongating and contracting.
So even though
skipping's a lot of fun,
it's a great way to
start strengthening
some of those running muscles.
These kind of workouts over time
push your lactate threshold,
meaning that your
fatigue level gets
further and further
out the more you do
this kind of intense training.
Then I did a series
of exercises designed
to strengthen their muscles.
And so I started with what we
call plyometric jump squats,
and those are like the
best exercise you can do.
They're awesome.
You basically squat
all the way down,
and then you jump up in the
air and squat all the way
back down.
Then I had people
get on the ground,
and I did a series of rotation
planks with a push-up.
And then legs down is when you
bring your legs all the way up
and then straight down.
Again, a great
core strengthener.
And then some
sit-ups, and the idea
is strengthening the whole
kinetic chain, all the muscles.
We started with the
legs and the glutes.
Then we went to the
core and the upper body.
Following that, we did
my favorite exercise,
which is called the burpee.
It was designed in the 1930s
to give maximum strength
and maximum effort.
And then we finished with
an isometric exercise called
a plank, and that's where you
hold yourself in one position
to strengthen all the
muscles around the core.
And that's the thing I
love about this class is
that it basically brings people
together of all different ages
and abilities, and it's
great, because as a group,
you can work so much harder
than you can individually.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JORDAN METZL: And it's fun.
I hope you guys come out.
So off to the races.
So everybody in
here needs a goal.
Following the
right training plan
I think is a way to do that.
Mental, run, and
physiology training
all kind of training
your physiology
to be an effective runner, I
think very important as well,
and thinking about
preventive health.
So are the two things
that we have here.
Actually we don't have the DVD.
Believe it or not, some
people still use DVDs.
Shocking, I know.
That's what I said
too, but they do.
But the run book is all
about all this stuff,
trying to teach people how to
be healthy and prevent injury.
Let's turn off the slides.
I'm going to show
you guys a demo, what
I was talking about
the tech piece of this,
just because my challenge-- so
I'll switch over to this, guys.
My challenge with this
was to basically--
I love everything
about this company
and what you guys do here.
The one problem as a doctor is
that Dr. Google is only right
about 30% of the time.
And every single
person comes in to see
me thinks they have bone
cancer, because they've used
Dr. Google, or Lyme disease.
And so it's been
kind of frustrating,
because they all use
Dr. Google, and like
if I was only right 30% percent
of the time, like you know.
So anyway, Dr. Google's a
great person, great doctor,
but he doesn't have
a very high hit rate.
So my challenge was basically
people don't only want to read.
They use Dr. Google
all the time.
So how to basically try and
control that information,
so it's more directed towards
what I think is more accurate.
So what I did is I
went to Runner's World
with this, so this is
a book number three
in a series of five
I've done with them.
And I said, listen, I've got
like 45, 50 of these videos
I've done with you over the
years on every single thing--
shin splints and plantar
fasciitis and everything--
and I want to figure out
a way to make the book
interface with the smartphone.
And they said, all right, we're
going to use this scanning app.
And so we picked an
app called Blippar,
which I'm going to show you.
There I am.
So this is how it works.
So basically, I'm going
to open the app, which
is a scanning app, and anything
I want to do, and whoop,
it just already found the cover
before I was ready for it.
So any question I
have inside the book,
so let's say I have
Achilles tendinitis here.
Can you guys see
the book as well?
On the camera, can
you move that at all?
Good, so here's somebody reading
about Achilles tendinitis,
and there's all
this stuff to do,
but just the reading
experience alone
is, I think, what
do I do exactly?
So anytime this
symbol is on the page,
the whole page is scannable.
So what then people do is
they hold the phone over that.
It pulls up the video
that links to that thing,
and then we have a video
I've done on that subject.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Achilles tendinitis,
I'm telling you,
I'm in here every single
day seeing patients.
They are really
frustrated, because they
come in, and they say,
hey, listen, Dr. Metzl,
I want to run.
And I can't run, because
my Achilles tendon is sore,
and it's been sore for awhile.
That's the common story in
here, so let's figure out
Achilles tendinitis.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JORDAN METZL: So
you get the idea.
So it kind of goes
through a much longer way
to think about that,
which has been cool
just in terms of interfacing
information, I think.
So I'm not a tech--
I mean, I love tech,
but I'm not a tech guy like
you guys are tech people.
But that was pretty awesome just
to be able to kind of, I think,
control that a little bit more.
So we just wanted to do a demo
of that, because I was like,
we're going to Google.
I've got to-- where else
am I going to show that?
So in conclusion, I want
you guys to run forever.
I want you to please join
what I'm doing community-wise.
I left some cards back there.
My website's on there.
Sign yourselves up for
this class or any class.
And I'm happy to answer any
questions about your running,
your health, or whatever.
I think we have a microphone
here for any questions,
or I'll just repeat them.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
JORDAN METZL: Yeah.
I'll repeat it for you.
Here comes the thing,
yeah, because they
were doing a webcast thing.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
A few slides back, you
talked about the way
the knee kind of went
in to the other foot,
so you're saying misalignment
of your hip, knee,
and foot is bad?
JORDAN METZL: It's bad, yeah.
I want you basically
to line yourself up
as directly between hip,
knee, and foot as you can.
And as I showed in
the video, sometimes
that's coming from the feet.
So sometimes the only problem
is you may be super strong,
but your foot's rolling in
like bad feet, good feet.
Sometimes you've got WBS, and
you're so weak on that side
it's happening from the hip
down, and sometimes it's both.
So the answer is that the more
we can kind of figure out,
and so I really try and teach
people how to fix themselves
from the ground up
and from the hip down
or the core down, and between
those things together,
that's most people.
Now some people have something
like that other dude, which
is their knee's arthritic.
No matter what I do,
they're still going to hurt.
So we have to think
about lube shots
or whatever else for them.
But in general, that's
the mechanical piece
is the short stride, high
cadence and lining you
up as best we can.
AUDIENCE: So do you
think it makes sense
to come in prior
to injury to say,
hey, am I misaligned
of the foot?
JORDAN METZL: I don't think so.
So I have a bunch of stuff in
here about how to do the step
down test on your own,
and do a lot of stuff you
can do on your own to screen
yourself and see, what am I
doing?
You can even go to
the running store,
and they can kind of
get a rough screen.
They have some stuff in there.
If you're like, I
keep getting hurt,
then we have the ability to
do full analysis in the thing.
But I want you-- I mean,
I'm happy to see you,
but you don't have to come
in unless there's a problem.
But I think you can do a
lot to prevent yourself
from having a problem.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: This was not
planned, I promise.
I have a quick question.
What do you think is the best
way to find a proper diagnosis
for knee pain?
I've had some
inconclusive MRI results,
and I'm just wondering
after a couple of those,
what you would do next.
JORDAN METZL: It's
a good question,
and the answer is try watching
some of these videos first,
and see if any of those resonate
with what your problem is,
where the pain is.
I try and line them up by where
it's hurting on your knee.
But generally, pain
happens for a reason.
So whether it's me
or somebody, I just
like for people that are
runners to find a doctor that
does that kind of stuff or any
kind of health professional
that they're going to
use that does that.
I think it just kind
of makes more sense,
because often, your only advice
will be, well, just don't run.
Well, yeah, dude, whatever.
Like that's not going to work.
I think that's a
piece [INAUDIBLE],
and then try and see
somebody that is doing
the stuff I think that helps.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JORDAN METZL: But pain
happens for a reason,
so there's usually a reason why.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
OK, that's working.
So I just had a quick question.
I'm a type 1 diabetic,
and I've been
trying to do-- I did
the marathon last year,
and I've trying to find a
training plan that'll actually
work for me, because I can't
do like glycogen loading.
Do you have any
advice on what to do?
JORDAN METZL: Nutritionally
you're saying?
AUDIENCE: Nutritionally.
JORDAN METZL: So that's
a tough question.
So type 1 diabetes are
people who basically
are born without a kind of
working insulin, so they need
insulin injections to control or
insulin to modify their stuff.
Is that correct for you?
Do you have a pump, or do
you administer yourself?
AUDIENCE: Uh, no,
I self-administer.
JORDAN METZL: So meaning
there's a pump which does that.
It kind of reads
your blood sugar
and will administer
insulin on its own,
or some people have to
give themselves shots,
and the problem is if
you don't have a pump,
you can be doing a race,
and you can bottom out,
and you don't know it during
or especially afterwards,
and you could have
a big problem.
So the answer is you are
somebody that really needs
to see a sport nutritionist.
On my site, I have
a link to a bunch,
and I have a bunch who run.
And you want to
basically figure out
with a running sport
nutritionist what's
happening along
the way with you,
and maybe even everything
from getting sample glucose
readings as you go on a
training run to see where you're
bottoming and how you can
kind of think about nutrition
strategies around that.
There's a lot to do in that.
But the reason why I
love you're doing that
is that diabetic
sugar control is
a big piece of the
equation about preventing
some of the longer term
complications for type 1
diabetes.
So I want you
running, and I don't
want that issue to be
prohibitive for you
in terms of not running.
So there's a lot to do
to think about that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JORDAN METZL: Sure.
AUDIENCE: How's it going?
Thanks for coming to speak.
I appreciate it.
I actually just had
a quick question
on what your thoughts
were on rotating shoes.
I myself, I like to rotate two
different brands to actually
teach my foot how to become
accustomed to longer distance
running versus the days
I'm doing workouts.
So I have specific
shoes that I use
when I'm doing speed
workout and then other shoes
when I'm going out for
long distance runs.
JORDAN METZL: So the fast
shoes and the slow shoes.
That's a great question.
And I think the answer
is that's terrific.
I like that a lot,
and I like even
doing shorter stuff in a
more minimalist, flatter,
less supportive shoe.
I got no problem
with that at all.
I think it builds foot strength.
It shortens your stride.
I think all the things
that you're finding,
I think it's-- I have no
problem with that at all.
Some people like that.
Some people don't like that.
And the answer is that if it
works for you, it works for me.
AUDIENCE: Awesome, thanks.
JORDAN METZL: All right, sure.
AUDIENCE: I have
a quick question.
So I wanted you to talk about
somewhat about conditioning.
So sometimes I go into a
sport somewhat unprepared
just after the work, so
it's already 6:30, 7:00.
I will grab something and get
into a basketball match, say.
And then after that,
we realize, oh, we just
jumped into the basketball
game, and here's
what we came out of it.
The next day we have
a sprain in our calf,
something in the
shoulder, our finger got
turned back while tackling.
So what's like a
one-minute conditioning
or five-minute conditioning
that you can do on the run?
JORDAN METZL: So weekend warrior
syndrome, so basically you're
kind of sitting all day,
go out, and get started.
So number one,
warming up your body.
So in my workout, I
have a lot of stuff
that's called dynamic
warmup like jumping jacks
and easy squats, air
squats, and walkouts,
and things to get your
body loose for four or five
minutes before you
just jump right
into a high ballistic activity.
I think that's
certainly helpful.
You'll see that in
there, number one.
Number two is a
preventive conditioning.
No matter what
sport you're doing,
you need one to two days
of strength training
per week, minimum one full
day of strength training.
Takes an hour.
You're going to learn
to love it eventually.
That will help prevent injury,
and then sometimes stuff
happens.
But in general,
those are the things
you can do the best is dynamic
warmup, functional training,
and then static stretching
after you're done
is certainly helpful, after the
event, while you're still warm.
AUDIENCE: Oh, after the event.
All right.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So we have a
15-story building here.
What are your
thoughts on stairs?
JORDAN METZL: I love stairs.
And so last time
I was down here,
I talked a lot
about the medicine
of exercise and increasing
your NEAT profile, which
is an acronym for Non-Exercise
Active Thermogenesis,
so you're just burning
calories from cruising around
during the day, which leads
to much more favorable health
outcomes across the board.
And things like stairs
and getting a dog
and walking to work or
taking a further subway,
all those things link to
better health characteristics,
and so those are
things anybody can do.
If you can do the stairs,
I love it for you guys.
And I think that's the reason
I like this workplace is
that it's very
ergonomically-- aside
from the fact it's cool--
it's very ergonomically
efficient in terms of getting
people to move around.
AUDIENCE: And then what
about as part of a workout?
Like how would you
incorporate stairs as--
JORDAN METZL: I think
stairs are plyometrics.
And so that's plyometric
based training.
I have no problem with that
at all once or twice a week
to build strength.
I have no problem
with stairs at all.
I'm happy to sign
anybody's books.
Thanks so much for
having me down.
I'll see you soon.
Bye.
[APPLAUSE]